what you expect to happen next week then
well we we will be meeting our employees
not the governments actually they don't
have a role directly in our pay
negotiations and in a way we're quite
pleased that they don't we we can
negotiate with our employers and we hope
we can resolve this distribute but I'd
like to say something about why we're
even in this position because
firefighters have voted in huge numbers
an overwhelming vote for strike action
but they don't do that lightly they've
done that because they've had 12 years
of endless attacks on their pay so that
on the basic rate of pay a competent
firefighter which more than half the
workforce are on is using the
government's preferred measure of CPI
some four thousand pounds a year worse
off than if we'd kept up with inflation
and you you know what no matter how much
you love your job and want to serve the
community at the end of the day people
have bills to pay rent to pay mortgage
to pay and families to look after and
people have been brought to that point
how much do firefighters get paid then
so competent firefighters is on just
over 32 000 pounds a year for a 42 hour
week so we're working longer than the
average working week for a basic pay our
members work permanent shifts generally
most of the overwhelming majority of
whole time firefighters work permanent
shifts including permanent weekends and
so on and that's for 32 000 pounds a
year with high rates of pension
contribution for example now you I think
I'm right saying you rejected a payoff
of five percent uh last November what
percentage are you looking for well we
started let's look at how it's unfolded
we were offered two percent uh and I've
got to say if perhaps if our employers
haven't started by offering two percent
our members might have might have
reacted differently I don't know uh by
then inflation had begun to take off so
significantly it wasn't me who rejected
five percent it was our members we put
it to a secret ballot and they voted by
79 to reject that yeah I'm not in a
position to say what would settle it
we're in discussions with our employers
and I'm not going to negotiate on scan
ITV but we we will be meeting him on
we're discussing with them this weekend
and tomorrow and we meet them on
Wednesday we hope would it be would it
be fair to say um and I I look we get
this a lot from union leaders
understandably you don't want to
negotiate live on TV
um but are you looking for a Payless to
match inflation double digits that's
effectively what you know the nurses
have given well it seems to me
personally that anything less than that
is a pay cut but that's for our members
to decide our members have to wipe all
sorts of things going on strike is not
easy you're going on strike is a
struggle people lose money when you when
I hear government ministers talk about
Union Barons calling people out on
strike they don't understand at all the
the real difficult decisions that
workers have when they go on strike so
our members will weigh up all sorts of
things I hope that the fire service
employers will come in and improve their
offer in a way that we can put to our
members and our members will decide for
themselves so um you know what the
government would say is look if they
give all public sector workers a pay
rise that matches inflation or even you
know is higher than inflation in some
cases that
air further Stokes inflation but also
it's unaffordable at a time when we are
spending more on our debt interest than
the entire education budget well first
of all there's no evidence whatsoever
the wages have caused this round of
inflation not that it calls but it will
make it worse there's no evidence that
public sector pay drives up inflation at
all it may lead to impacts on taxation
but let's look at the mess we're in it
wasn't firefighters or teachers or
nurses who cause the economic mess we
are in we see in the Press today that
Liz trust trying to redeem herself well
perhaps the conservative government
should look a bit closer to home as to
who caused the economic chaos that
working people are now being asked to
pay for are you concern that lives could
be put at risk if firefighters can't
strike well of course we don't
underestimate the seriousness of what we
are doing and and our members understand
that but as I say at the end of the day
people have uh families to look after in
terms of safety uh we are the government
has brought in legislation long before
this new legislation to require fire
services to put in place resilience
plans as it's described contingency
arrangements and each year they're
supposed to check now we've always been
assured by ministers and by Chief Fire
officers that all those plans are
perfectly adequate so that's their
responsibility the question about Public
Safety is one that sits with the
government and with Chief Fire officers
it is their responsibility not the
responsibility of firefighters
the safety is on is is at the door of
the government and others not individual
uh firefighters but if I just want to
look at for example this is a Holland of
the West Midland fire brigades union he
said we expect fire services to depend
on the small number who choose not to
strike to provide cover during any
periods of action it goes on to say you
know there will be an agreement that
allows firefighters and control staff to
respond to Major incidents during strike
action if they wish to do so I mean it
sounds an awful lot like you are putting
you know safety on individual
firefighters we need to look at the
legal response the legal responsibility
sits with the Fire Authority and the
Chief Fire officer we have a reached
since 2002 in any dispute we've had
we've reached what's called a major
incidence agreement that allows
firefighters to return to work in cases
of majors and that's negotiated at a
national level and then applied at a
local level well Billy Holland will be
reflecting what his chief officer has
said in the West Midlands as they have
all over the country don't worry about
it and we can provide the quotes where
they have said I.E the chief officers
don't worry I've got it all in hand they
they've never spoken to us about any of
this by the way the chief officers there
will not have been negotiating with
Billy though the details of what they
have in place that's as I say a matter
for the chief I guess you know look
you're talking about the legal
responsibility and I'm sure you're
completely right you know your guy who's
very across the details I I defer to you
on it but I guess I'm just talking about
the the gut instinct that people have
you know the fear that people will have
oh my gosh the fire brigade is going on
strike am I going to be safe what if
there's a big fire what's going to
happen well Sophie the the we did not
call strikes we announced before we I'm
not talking about blame
there is a big fire what happened we
delayed calling any strikes for 10 days
to allow our employers to negotiate a
settlement we want to avoid a strike in
the first place at the re we've got to
look at why there are strikes in a key
sector's Health ambulance fire service
because 12 years of driving down workers
wages you
you've made your point you know
eloquently about you know who is to
blame for the strike in your view you
know the government the cuts people
can't get a decent living that they're
working long hours in the fire brigade
service putting all of that to one side
my question I guess is what happens if
there is a big fire do people attend if
there is a big fire and that's a major
incident and as I say we've got an
agreement that allows a return to work
in certain circumstances that's happened
in previous disputes in fact a
conservative Minister approached me
during one such incident and a return to
it was agreed that's happened in the
past and it's we've seen it happen in
other sectors so we have examples of
where we have resolved those particular
sorts of threats so you're confident
that lives won't be put at risk by their
strength the question of whether safety
is put at risk is one that sits with the
government and with three fire officers
so you can't answer that question now I
can't answer that because I'm not
involved in those discussions okay now
we'll talk to laborers Jonathan Reynolds
um directly after this interview and I'm
interested to know what your message is
to him because labor so far we said look
you know we would get around the table
with striking workers we would try and
negotiate a settlement but they haven't
given any guidance on what kind of
payoff would they be prepared to give
well I think trade Unions would probably
and Trade union members would probably
see uh want to see labor more clearly on
the side of workers the labor parties
was created by workers organizations and
you would hope that labor MPS and labor
leaders and so on would
see the justice of our cause so I think
there's a bit of frustration there uh
nevertheless many labor MPS have
supported us and we we welcome that I
think we would want to see more clear
support that actually these disputes
need to be resolved there need to be pay
Rises you can't endlessly drive down the
wages of public sector workers and
expect public services to function and
that's the crisis we're in you've got
hundreds of thousands of workers in
health in Ambulance Service teachers are
now in the fire and rescue service
saying actually we can't go on like this
we need to be able to pay the bills at
the end of the month and nobody's doing
anything to address that while I've got
you
um an independent report into the London
Fire brigades Union found in November
some pretty awful examples of racism and
sexism in the force female firefighters
groped people having their helmets
filled with urine a Muslim firefighter
having bacon and sausages stuffed in his
pockets What's the culture alone it
should be clear that wasn't into the
London fire brigade Union that was into
the London fire brigade yes
we don't run the London so into the
London fire brigade I don't run the
London fire brigade I think that is a
shocking report and there are other
shocking reports which have been in the
media over the past couple of weeks
though the people affected by that in
most cases are members of our Union and
each year we have to end up taking for
example cases to employment tribunal on
behalf of members who've been
discriminated against bullied and
harassed there has been far little done
by Chief Fire officers frankly for 30
years in terms of recruitment equality
making sure the fire service itself is
more diverse making sure that management
teams are more diverse that's a complete
failure of the people running the fire
and rescue service and yes it should be
addressed we seek to build a workplace
which is welcoming and most fire service
workplaces are welcoming to people from
all sorts of backgrounds so these These
are horrific examples but they're
clearly not everywhere and what we have
uh We've created special sections we
have a women's section LGBT section
black members section to make sure that
the views of underrepresented groups in
the fire service are heard within our
Union I can't talk for management
structures but within our Union they are
heard and we've we've uh attempted I was
interested when you said that there's
been effectively failure of leadership
over 30 years and do you think that they
get it now or do you think they'll
actually more needs to be done I don't
know whether they get now because we we
hear a lot of platitudes frankly and
there's a lot of tick box exercises
where people say we've introduced a new
policy I'm not sure that just a new
policy is adequate to do this if you go
back 20 when some of these debates
started there was joint working with us
because the vast majority of the
workforce are members of our Union I've
been you know 25 years ago uh doing
joint seminars actually that most of
that has ended so first of all equality
teams have been cut back as part of the
cuts there has been a retreat the the
the first thing the coalition government
in 2010 did was scrap all equality
targets so there's been a the foot taken
off the gas by central government as
well in relation to equality in the fire